wonderful to be here guys I'm so excited
I this is true I got stuck behind a
motorcycle on my way to work today
completely true motorcycle come to work
and that it wasn't one of those like
dangerous bike gang motorcycles but like
a dork I guess like a dork Motors I go
you know I'm dying around like they're
too wide there's a pod in the back like
a mini trunk like you gotta have my
stuff I keep my retainer in my bike home
what I'm saying there's two types of
people who ride motorcycles the cool guy
who fits in with the whole motorcycle
gang thing and then there's the fella
who just happens to be on a two-wheeled
outside car here in my point if I set I
say if you're gonna ride a motorcycle be
the cool biker don't be a dork
motorcycles aren't for dorks that's why
I don't ride one I'm a dork I wish I
could seriously every time I see a biker
I go someday
never been on one run like that's in my
future then I continue putting along in
my VW Golf the pandera Spanish guitar
station shuffling at a reasonable volume
chilled yoohoo within easy reach torque
not a biker dork don't get me wrong I'm
not making fun of actual bikers I don't
want to die I mean they probably don't
watch the show I don't think they're
like whoo boys stop pillaging Detroit
Pete Home Show zone
I'm making fun of the weird couple from
Appleton Wisconsin with the matching
wide bikes that can't fall over wearing
huge helmets like those crew members on
the evil ship and Spaceballs you know
I'm talking about the perfect circle
just like with the built-in
walkie-talkie so they can talk to one
another like sweetums there's a waffle
house three exits up ready my insulin
it's in the bike huh yeah it's in the
hub it's in the hop it's in your hump
insulins in your hump sleep apnea
machines in ma huh what I'm saying if
you're a biker and I'm not scared of you
you're doing it wrong